hello everyone and welcome to round
seven of the skilling open preliminaries
uh it's a
it's a very wild game between temura
jabo and levon arnan
and uh it's uh hard to choose which one
to show there are so many games and they
are rapid games uh and i still haven't
decided whether i'm going to show more
than one game a day
uh as uh ever since i've returned from
surgery i've
been keeping it uh at a one uh video per
day
pace but we'll see maybe maybe i can
squeeze in a few more
uh so i chose this one because i've seen
a lot of people have already shown some
other games
but this one is uh is very enjoyable so
i do hope you guys enjoy it as well
so rajab with the white pieces uh opens
with
d4 now we have knight to f6 by 11 c4 and
now e6
going for the uh well uh some sort of an
uh some sort of an indian defense
depends on what white plays we have
knights to f3 so the sword uh
the so-called anti-nimso variation as it
uh doesn't allow
bishop to be for to come with a pin uh
and here d5 by black and we've just
basically transposed into the queen's
gun but declined knight to c3 and now
bishop to e7
we have bishop to f4 and now uh we have
castles by black
and here e3 not just continuing
development
the light square bishop can now be
developed with knight bd7
and a3 uh we have c6 uh and now bishop
to e2 so this is all very standard stuff
played uh
lots of times uh d captures its usual
you
black will always wait for white to
develop this light square bishop before
capturing on c4 uh if
black uh uh decides to capture on c4
so captures captures uh so white would
not uh gain a tempo by
uh just capturing and then allowing the
white to capture on
uh c4 right away uh with b5 bishop back
to d3 and
now a6 closing this position like this
as
at some point you might want to play c5
so we wanted the b5 pawn to be protected
and you might consider something like
bishop b7 rook c8 c5
and so on uh however here uh rajab goes
b4 and
it's a new move in the position and it's
uh very interesting because it's not all
that clear
how black will execute c5 at any point
since
the the b and d pawn are covering the c5
square nicely
so here uh arunian immediately goes a5
he says okay i don't have to play like
that i can open up the a
file so rook to b1 and here 11 trades
captures captures and now bishop to b7
rook to a3 seems like a very active move
as it's uh
it's a very nice active move with the
rook also attacks the knight however
queen c1
defends and attacks simultaneously and
you're just going to have to
bring the rogue back and you could also
maybe bring it to a6 but it doesn't seem
like it's
gaining anything so instead bishop to b7
and now comes queen to c2 putting
pressure on this h7 pawn
and while you can play h6 at any point
uh it could be a bit risky black still
hasn't castle so you don't know if he's
even play uh white
uh you still don't know if he's playing
the castle he might
have some uh h49 g5 ideas planned
with some sacrifices so who knows uh we
have knight to b6 now the knight can
come to c4
and d5 and here rajabov prevents the
knight from coming to d5
he plays e4 but really he's preparing e5
to kick away the knight
and uh well uh by doing so the defender
of the h7 square
with knight to c4 here now threatening
knight to a3 to win material
as the queen and rook will be under
attack and now bishop to c1 the bishop
now
defends the a3 square and here uh 11
could go knight to a3
just the same force white to give up the
dark square bishop
however he decides to go knight to d7
and it's it's a very interesting uh move
because uh you could just play h6 and
you don't have to worry about this
bishop ever capturing the h7 pawn after
e5 is played but he goes for this
different line he
he allows the pawn to be captured and he
says okay your king is still in the
center of the board
this is a rapid game so you know things
are going to get crazy i'm going to give
you the h7 pawn so he goes knight to d7
and here e5 uh so the h7 pawn is
threatened and now
if you don't want to play something like
g6 uh to
defend against uh bishop captures uh you
have to try something else so here
11 plays f5 he says uh okay you can
capture alpha song
and then i'm gonna capture on h7 and uh
my king in the center of the board will
be perfectly fine so let's see
uh how uh arajava deals with this he
captures on f6
uh we have bishop captures and now he
grabs the pawn bishop captures on h7
king h8 by 11 and now bishop back to e4
you don't want to allow this bishop to
be captured also there are some tricks
as this bishop is still in b7 so you
might consider something like knight
captures captures and bishop to b7 in
some lines
uh and here we have e5 by eleven
so now the d4 pawn is under attack uh
it's uh uh it's being attacked twice and
the white has to decide what to do here
whether he's going to castle whether
he's going to try for some knight
captures on b5 action
but he already grabbed the pawn and
rajab wants to
to keep the e file closed as his king is
still in the center of the board
and obviously he still hasn't decided
whether he's going to castle or whether
he wants to do something like h4 knight
g5 rook h3 later on
so here d5 keeping the e file closed and
now
c captures on d5 we have knight captures
uh and now
queen to c8 and what do you do here
well here if the knight moves then the
queens could get traded off
uh so instead we have queen to e2 by
rajabov
and now comes knight to d6 here the
queen from e2 is eyeing that
h5 square so if the knight moves you
could have some
problems here after bishop to h7 you
know the the bishop h7 to g6 action
followed by queen h7 checkmate
so here knight to d6 attacking the light
square bishop here
saying okay i'm not going to allow you
to do that you can move the bishop and
after you move the bishop i'm just going
to play something else for example if
you play bishop to d3
then of course uh ideas like e4 come to
mind and
it's just going to be much better for
black however
after this knight to d6 move uh 11
missed one idea from
job of now feel free to pause the video
and find this
absolutely winning idea while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
uh
well you can always give up one of the
pieces if
you can checkmate your opponent
afterwards and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's knight the g5 and now you see uh
black is facing some serious serious
difficulties
as queen to h5 check is coming and even
though you can capture both the bishop
and the knight uh it simply doesn't work
so we're gonna try
capturing the knight first the problem
is uh after queen to h5 check whatever
black plays the black is lost
if you go king to g8 right away uh you
face knight the e7
check first uh because uh if you just
try this idea bishop h6 followed by
bishop
bishop h7 followed by bishop to g6 check
black will uh sorry
black will block with the bishop so by
by uh playing knight
the e7 check first you are forcing black
to capture because the king has nowhere
to go
all of these squares are covered so
bishop captures and now you are free to
checkmate the black king so just bishop
h7 check of course this is covered
king here check here and then it's
checkmate so this is what happens uh if
you
after queen to h5 check decides to move
the king
another idea which is of course much
better is bishop to h6 right away but it
also doesn't work because just
bishop captures an h6 and now uh you
you have nothing if k if the pawn
captures then just captures followed by
checkmate
and if you try something like rook to f6
to make some breeding room for the king
again doesn't work just bishop e3 a
discovered check and after you move the
king now comes knight to e7 check you
win the queen
and this game over so this is what
happens after this knight to g5 move
if the knight is captured so you might
think but
why not capture the bishop instead and
then maybe we can we can do something
with that
also doesn't work because it's now a
very clean check made into just queen h5
checking the g8 and queen to h7
equals checkmate because the knight
unlike the bishop can cover the f7
uh and the h7 squares both from from
here
uh bishop can also do that from g6 uh
you know
but the bishop was not on g6 uh so here
uh after knight the g5 uh we have a
third idea
uh which uh i was following this game in
the live feed and the commentators
didn't even take this into consideration
which is
uh the the best uh move by the engine
but it's a hard
hardest spot but it's not hard to spot
if this is losing and this is losing
uh which 11 obviously calculated so
queen captures on c1 11 decides to give
up the queen
the uh you know survive a little bit
longer and maybe try to pose some
problems for
rajabov so here rook captures on c1 was
played
and now bishop captures on g5 attacking
the rook here on c1
and rook to d1 now so here white of
course is up material black doesn't have
a
sufficient compensation for the queen
but of course it's a rapid game many
pieces are on the board
so of course a lot of things can still
happen and the white king is still in
the center of the board so here
we have a few traits knight captures on
e4 queen captures and now comes
knight to f6 with a double attack on the
knight here and if you don't want to
give up the rook
you have to find the queen to g6 or f5
for that matter which comes with an
attack on the bishop
and also just unpinning from from the
bishop's grasp remember how this bishop
was completely
locked in by spawns now it's uh now it's
uh
a very strong piece and it comes alive
so here uh
bishop captures on the five and queen
captures on g5 now also defending the g2
pawn
uh we have bishop to c4 and now comes
rook to c1
uh we have bishop to d3 now also maybe
with ideas of e4
and now comes rook to c7 and now uh
rajabov is threatening checkmate so you
need a passive move with black so here
we have rook to g8 uh the rook is now a
bit passive but
you you have defended against checkmate
queen h4 check
uh forcing one of the pieces to retreat
to not there but retreat to h7
knight to h7 and now king to d2 uh
preparing to bring the the other rook
into the game with tempo as the bishop
here is under attack
so uh you could defend it with e4 but it
doesn't really matter
uh as uh white uh is simply up too much
material so here rook
8 to b8 threatening some nasty
discoveries
but here uh rajab shows exactly that
there are no nasty discoveries because
you have a light square bishop and all
of
uh all of the important stuff in white's
camp occupies the dark squares
so not not a lot to do here bishop c for
check a nice discovered check by the
rook
king he won and now rook to d4 attacking
the queen we have queen to e7
uh and now rook to e4 check king d2 and
now uh
knight to f6 uh delivering one check on
e2 doesn't really do anything king d1 or
king c3
perfectly fine for white black doesn't
really have a good way of continuing
this so after king d2 we have knight to
f6 trying to get this knight into the
game if the rook moves the 94
check could be could be very interesting
however rook to c3 and now there is not
much black can do against rook to h3
check
so here rook to e2 check was played king
to d1 and now
rook captures an f2 but that's just it
rook to h3 check by the job of
knight to h7 and now uh well you could
finish this game in a variety of ways uh
queen to h4 being one of them
threatening checkmate and the rook here
on f
on f2 rajava does the well
more more aesthetically pleasing move
rook captures on h7
and it was in this position that levon
aaron resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
once the rook is captured just queen h4
check picks up the rook here
and now black is down simply too much
material after a king here
queen captures here on f2 and that's
just it a broken queen against a rook
and bishop of course
completely winning for rajabov
so after rook captures on h7 uh arnon
resigned and
wha what a victory for a job of who is
uh one step closer to surviving the
well the first three days of the
preliminaries and here just so
uh we don't uh miss the standings these
are the stan
nope no they're not these are the
standings after they one these are the
standings after day two so let's just
check them out
on each giri uh in seoul lead with six
and a half out of ten
followed by three people um with six
points uh dingler and magnus carlson and
wesley so
uh then we have nakamura with five and a
half uh out of ten
uh well three people as well uh nakamura
uh maksim bashola gavin nyani palmishi
with five and a half out of ten
then with five out of ten uh we have uh
rajab of anton
tangiharo and alireza firuja uh with
four and a half out of ten eliquan liam
eleven aaron and sergey karakin and with
four uh with four out of ten peter
svidler
visited gujarati with three and a half
out of ten and currently in last place
young shisht of duda
but what's uh amazing here the
difference between first
place and let's say uh well first place
is six and a half points
uh and already nine place is only five
points
so a point and a half difference between
uh giri who's in first place and for
example
uh anton guihara who will not be
participating in the tournament if uh if
he remains in ninth place so it's gonna
be
uh incredibly intense as third day yeah
is starting today so we're gonna see
what happens should be uh should be you
know pretty pretty crazy and everyone's
gonna be fighting to
uh to remain in the tournament after the
preliminaries
uh so uh that's uh that's the game i do
hope you enjoyed it brilliant victory by
rajab
i would like to thank michael
francischini uh john anderson the
dimitro zemensky juan vincent alvarez
and kiriakous for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day